this week on ford my conversation with
philosopher rapper contemporary
intellectual coleman hughes excited for
this one on forward this week
[Music]
this week on ford it is my pleasure to
welcome philosopher
rockstar uh one of in my mind one of the
most
uh interesting modern-day intellectuals
of our era coleman hughes welcome
coleman it's honor to be here uh i am so
pumped to have you here and i think this
might be a a crossover episode so i i
might be showing up on your yeah so
welcome to conversations with coleman
yes look at this it's the yang coleman
crossover that the world has been wanted
demanding yeah yes
we could we couldn't uh put off the
masses any longer yeah uh so so pumped
to meet you i feel like i've known you
for a long time yeah likewise yeah yeah
so on my side what happened was there
was this gathering of folks i think that
you and i are friendly with it was like
uh sam harris
uh some other folks got together and
like you were there too
uh and i was like ooh who's this
oh that's right the whole thing that
never happened yeah that whole event
that never happened yeah that's what it
was that the pangburn philosophy event
that was like uh
it was like the intellectual equivalent
of the fire festival it was like the
lollapalooza of thinkers yeah
i wonder it would be barry farrell and
that one maybe sam yeah uh yes so i i
thought to myself like wow
coleman's really impressive
and so i've been trying to keep up with
your work since then in some ways but
more recently you hit the radar in a
huge way when you became a legitimate
rock star it came out with like a music
video
that i thought was brilliant thank you
thank you
yeah uh i mean i i remember
i do remember we were gonna do that
event and i was following you i heard
you on sam harris's podcast years ago
and and then you ran for president and
you were
i think probably
as much or more than any other candidate
aligned with
what i wanted to see
and then you ran for mayor
and i was rooting for you there
as a new yorker
and uh you know like as someone who
i'm not a registered democrat or a
republican
you know i've always felt
a genuine kind of centrist
politics
a moderation about me that's you know
sometimes people just seem like a
moderate fellow i'm a pretty moderate
fellow i mean
depends depends when you catch me
well you know what one of the things we
can discuss this too is that you can
have big visions for things that need to
change
um and be moderate in either temperament
or approach or language right
like i still think for example we should
give everyone
some money
which some people regard as as a radical
idea yes right i i see it as very
reasonable and uh
and moderate
um but i'd love to get into your origin
story for people because there are a lot
of people that
want to be philosophers
and
aren't
[Laughter]
or maybe they are
i'll actually confess my story too and
you might and i share some things in
common so i i went to
uh prep school and college in new
england um and there was a point when i
was a bit of a philosophy buff or
wannabe philosophy buff so i did i'm
like there are probably some people
listening to this who resemble this so i
took an intro to philosophy class uh in
college
uh and wow was it not what i thought it
was going to be like i ended up being
kind of
shell-shocked or blown out of the water
in terms of like the nature of the stuff
we were reading and i i confess that was
like my first and last philosophy
wait what was it about the class that
shocked you well you know i i thought it
was going to be um closer to some stuff
i'd so i'd taken an existentialism class
and so i thought that the philosophy
class was going to be like that but
maybe because the intro to philosophy
class went like further back in time it
wasn't reading
like greek philosophers or any of that
jazz it was like steps earlier than that
i don't know if maybe that was just
earlier than the greeks yeah it was or
it was like it wasn't what i thought it
was going to be and it was much more
what's earlier than the greeks or
seriously uh
sumerians i don't know
yeah i just remember being put off by it
and so that was like my dalliance with
yeah with philosophy i did study
political science which ends up
intersecting with it so that brought in
the mills hobbs right
like
those thinkers that ended up influencing
you know the social contract
my background in philosophy started i
suppose when i was
17 i took a philosophy class in high
school
and i clearly had a knack for it but i
had no concept that that would be my
college major
at that time i was a musician through
and through i was like mentally done
with school
just so you grew up
i grew up in new jersey i grew up in
montclair new jersey which is like a 30
minute drive outside the city
as in new york city
and
i uh
i have two sisters uh you know two
parents
grew up in a beautiful
uh diverse and and well-off suburb
and
as a kid i was always very good at
school
i i was uh i got very good grades
and
i enjoyed getting good grades
and
really the
the feature of my identity that evolved
most intensely was music so what was
your instrument
so i played violin when i was three
and i was okay i was i was sort of
better than average but nothing to write
home about and i did the suzuki method
which a lot of kids do
and i started piano at five
until i was about 12.
yeah i went uh i went
until college i played piano for i
suppose i took construction for 12 years
but continue like classical yep yeah
i had a puerto rican tiger mom
so i i was i was uh
violin
that three is pretty intense
yeah
uh drums at seven or eight which i was
the best of all three at and my school
that my the public school i went to
montclair hillside
from third to fifth grade had this thing
called drums of thunder which was a drum
line of 10 and 11 year olds
that would do
pieces almost like do you remember that
uh
that movie i think it's called drumline
from like oh yeah 15 years ago with nick
cannon yeah
so we did that
stuff as 10 and 11 year olds
and we were so good that we would
perform half time for the new york
giants the new year i've seen the new
york jets you've sent you've seen drums
of thunder yeah it's called drums of
thunder
that was really my first taste of music
performance it was like insane
like i was 10 years old and lebron james
just walked right past me as i walked
onto
half court at the washington wizards or
something yeah and we played and
the way that group was run by the
there's this charismatic director named
vinnie d'amico
and he would run it like a sort of mock
army he would have us do like
10 hut yup type things with the sticks
and it was like this discipline exercise
that we really enjoyed
and parents obviously loved it because
like we were all
cute and like
cute yet disciplined cute disciplined
yeah it was just an incredible
experience but he ran it on like a
military structure so the best drummer
would audition for the role of commander
and i got the commander of the group in
fifth grade so i was i was i had talent
for for drumming yeah
and then i went from sixth grade i went
to a private school called newark
academy in livingston new jersey which
had a really nice orchestra
and i started playing in the orchestra
got fed up with playing the drums
because in in a
orchestra drums is you just count like
400 bars of rest and then you have one
note
and then it's another and you have to
unleash the drummer within yeah exactly
so that's when i started playing
trombone
in sixth grade and i ended up getting
really good at trombone to the point
that i was you know at 17 or 18
considered
one of the best jazz trombonists my age
in the country
so i i auditioned for juilliard out of
high school and they took three people
and i was one of those three wow so did
you go i did yeah i went to juilliard
for about
five
months maybe
and then i dropped out
so this is fascinating so you're getting
really good grades you're also something
of a jazz prodigy
and so
uh you must have had a very big choice
to make is like am i going to be
a professional musician or am i going to
go to like a school and then play music
on the side is that no easy choice super
easy choice i was like music
wow
so deep so you went to juilliard for
five months
and how was that uh you know as far as
music schools go it's one of the best
so i really i have nothing bad to say
about it
and the the people
my friends there remain some of my best
friends to this day
uh but music school in general i found
was not really for me it was also a time
of great turmoil in my life because my
mother was dying i don't know and she
had cancer
and so i was really
i was suffering through
watching her die and asking questions
like you know what is it what is the
point of anything if you can just
die of cancer at 55
you know seemingly randomly
and
you know i
that really shook
a lot of assumptions i made about what i
wanted to do with my life and i was very
depressed and grieving
so she died in february of my freshman
year at juilliard oh i'm so sorry i i
dropped out
um
and
began really reevaluating what i wanted
to do with my life
i was also seeing that the kind of gigs
i would have to take in order to make it
as a professional trombone player
basically you have to take every gig
right there's like
and a lot of those gigs
are grueling and they suck and they
don't pay that much
and so i was seeing my future
and it didn't look
all that bright it felt like i could
probably do
music on the side if i wanted to but
also pursue something else if i stayed
in new york
and so i was reading a lot at that time
dealing with the loss of my mother
and i wanted to do i wanted to
i felt it would make more sense to do a
college degree
where
i could ask the kind of big questions i
was obsessing over
as a contemplative
person
but also stay in new york and be able to
do music to my heart's content
and so i dropped out of juilliard
and
re-applied to columbia where i had also
applied out of high school i figured i'd
get in again if i got in the first time
i did
and then i went to columbia
and did philosophy because it was the
only
subject where you can
ask
the big questions like what is the
meaning of life
uh without being ridiculed
or told that they're irrelevant or not
sufficiently rigorous or
all the rest
wow uh well
i'm so sorry for your your family's well
i didn't know this about your uh your
history
uh
so you transferred to colombia studied
philosophy
uh
and
you started receiving public notice
pretty quickly i want to say i think you
might still have been a student yeah
yeah i think i was a sophomore
yeah i was a sophomore at columbia
late in my sophomore year i started
pitching
well the kind of the whole time i'd been
pitching articles to places and trying
to write for the campus newspaper
um sometime successfully
um usually getting rejected
rejected because
you know it's
because
the
the range of acceptable opinions at the
columbia spectator is like this
so like most new york times op-eds would
be too right-wing for the columbia
spectator because you had divergent
views okay
so
eventually
i i my friend christian
christian gonzalez
he had
well actually i was reading colette at
the time
and i saw an article about martin luther
king and malcolm x examining both of
their legacies
and i thought it was really good and it
was written by this guy christian
gonzalez so i looked him up and he went
to colombia and then we became best
friends and he's oh wow one of my best
friends to this day fantastic but then
that gave me the idea well if this guy
can write for colette what's stopping me
nothing we're like the same sure so i
developed a following on quillette which
led to me going on sam harris's podcast
dave rubin's podcast and then eventually
starting my own podcast so you were
writing as a college sophomore junior
and then sophomore junior yep and senior
i was writing throughout that whole
period for for various outlets and you
gained some notice um it it it uh
strikes me that your
takes were probably again somewhat
divergent from
uh the those of the people around you
was there any like uh
issue did people
anyone
um take issue with your perspectives on
campus
yeah i mean i so the thing is
i'm not a very aggressive or
confrontational guy
so one on one i could have a
conversation with
anyone who disagrees with me
and it almost never
gets hostile
because i listen by default and i'm
curious about disagreements and
i'm not
abrasive
particularly i mean you seem very even
to me yeah yeah
so one-on-one i was never
ostracized really
but i was told by a lot of my friends
that behind my back people talked [ __ ]
about me so i i have to trust that that
happened
that i was fairly well known
as far as these things go on campus for
being
the black guy with the wrong opinions
and um
so i'm told that that was true you know
what what i
actually experienced though aside from
the occasional stuff like
i once matched with a girl on tinder
and it was like
going very well in the chat it was in
fact going so well
that she was she was a fan of a jazz
band that i play in called the mingus
big band she was like that's pretty good
it came up that she loved this band and
i was like i'm in that band so i was
like wow that's that's the best
beginning of a tinder conversation i've
ever had
and then she was like what else do you
do and i was like oh well i write
and she looked at my articles for
collette and she was like i'm sorry i
can't i can't go on a date with somebody
that thinks racism doesn't exist it's
like what
of course i don't think racism doesn't
exist
did you read my articles they were
anyway so aside from the occasional
thing like that most of what i
experienced was
people coming up to me privately and
being like
i kind of agree with you like
things are kind of nuts around here we
can't talk about anything
but like they wouldn't publicly
like my articles on facebook or or
anything like that but privately they
would they would
often agree with me
well everything i've seen of yours and i
haven't read everything you've produced
but everything i've seen of yours just
seems very lucid and reasonable and if
someone has an issue with it then you
know they they should try and dig in and
be like well okay here's uh what i
disagree with
um but it doesn't seem like that's the
tenor of things where instead there is
kind of this
uh more
visceral emotional uh response that that
unfortunately in my mind doesn't
necessarily lead to
uh give and take
no no it does not
but that that emerges
when people are in groups
people act crazy when they're in groups
one-on-one
i i can honestly say i've almost never
had a
really bad conversation with someone
one-on-one
even if there's
one or if there's four people in a room
you can feel it change because now
people are watching right and and a
whole different
mental machinery comes on board when you
feel like
your reputation
hangs in the balance
right that's when you get this
this like your evil kind of thing
there's like this sense that people
don't actually feel something
um but then they have to
act like they feel that when someone
else is there observing them right
i mean and it's like
we all know what happens at for instance
congressional hearings where every
congress
every congress person is
trying to get their 15 seconds of
something to get them on cable news it's
like they don't actually care about the
fbi guy they're grilling
they're thinking about it from their
perspective thinking i'm trying to build
my political brand i need to get some
media time i need to say something
that's going to get me 15 seconds of
play on fox on msnbc etc right
there's a microcosm of that a little
version of that
whenever people are watching right it's
like
we're all
sort of politicians and sort of brands
in a smaller way
and when we feel like our reputation is
at stake that if we
if we lose this argument our status is
going to go down in the group we act
very differently than when it's
one-on-one and nothing is at stake other
than
you know actually communicating with the
person in front of us yeah i certainly
had that experience i mean i've met with
thousands of americans individually and
99.9 percent of them are very
yeah
reasonable
and cordial
uh i've also interacted with thousands
of people on social media
that's the ultimate case where it's just
like pure [ __ ]
almost 100 of the time it is funny
because people like you and i you know
we utilize social media because we're
trying to reach people yeah yeah but
then also you see the
um
the drawbacks of it and you're like wow
there's so much so you can so you can
see the dynamic in social media too
because i mean i without even i don't
know if your dms are open on twitter yes
they are they are yeah as as are mine
and i read them i i don't have time to
respond i confess that i don't read okay
that's fine
but
if you ever have you'll notice they're
way higher quality
and way more interesting and way nicer
than the replies
in general
because again nobody's watching
that's a conversation between two people
so the the temperature of it is way
cooler
than
the public stuff this is a beef i have
too it's like there are people on
twitter who say things sometimes that i
know and it's like you just dm me
yeah yeah yeah
i mean right
you know we know each other yeah
it's kind of it's for public consumption
i guess right yeah
and so that's one thing that i pride
myself on not doing
is like i i don't
i generally don't engage in these like
uh
social media conversations that have
that performative feel where like uh you
know it's like hey i'm going to chime in
on something that
i sense you agree with and then you know
people will like me more and say i'm
saying
let's get that the other strange thing i
bet you've had this experience too
is that you see stuff being said about
people that you actually
know or kind of know and you're just
like oh like that's not yeah that's not
right that's not cool yeah um because to
most other people that person's just
like some avatar that some some you know
someone in the press like has an axe to
grind with
that you're like a real person yeah yeah
you know the real person the thing about
it also is like it's tempting to
just completely turn it off or go away
but
one of the things i find is that
for every 10
or 100
really dumb
or or just
nasty petty comments people make one
person will post a link to something to
a study to an article that is really
really interesting
and i don't want to miss out on that one
in 100 because it it happens pretty
reliably so
coleman hughes learns on social media i
swear to god
there's
i probably there's probably in the past
month two or three really interesting
studies that i would not have found out
it's if not for the crowd sourced one in
100 wisdom of
joe shmoe on twitter so i that's why i
look at it
yeah i know i i get it i get insight too
uh
people send me interesting stuff people
know what i'm about too so they'll send
me ai studies and yeah
things around right
polarization
you know what you love to do you know
what i love to do you know what you do
for six seven eight hours a day or night
it's sleep
and because we love to sleep so much we
really should be paying attention to the
mattress that we're sleeping on you can
get a mattress that's personalized for
you your body type your sleep
preferences at helix
sleep.com you can take a two-minute quiz
and they will send you a mattress risk
free don't take my word for it helix was
awarded the number one best overall
mattress pick of 2020 by gqn wired
magazine it's recommended by
chiropractors and doctors as a go-to
solution for improving your sleep just
go to helix sleep.com yang take their
two minute sleep quiz and they will
match you to a customized mattress
10-year warranty 100 nights risk-free i
know would be weird to return a mattress
at 9.99 but you can do it helix even has
some financing options if you want to do
some kind of layaway action and helix is
offering up to 200 off all mattress
orders and two free pillows for our
listeners at helixsleep.com
yang get the mattress to the sleep your
life helix sleep.com yang
[Music]
so
you're
graduating from columbia
um and you have a podcast at that point
at the time i graduated i i had recorded
a couple episodes but i hadn't released
them yet i hadn't developed i didn't
really have a podcast yet yeah so then
what what did you think okay what's my
next step did wait wait i know
mckinsey consulted
you know what was interesting about
mckin so
what is it called when uh you're
basically auditioning to become a
mckinsey consultant there's a word for
it they're like case interviews maybe
yeah that sounds right so when you're
doing that
uh
the the culture at columbia
was
i don't even know what the word is like
i would say phony but the cult the the
culture at columbia was such that
a lot of kids that were doing that doing
the case auditioning thing didn't want
people to know they were doing it
they didn't want to be seen as a sellout
that would do consulting interesting so
they would do it
but like tell their like one best friend
and swear them to secrecy don't tell
anyone what i'm doing and it wasn't just
because of fear of failure like they
don't want people to know if they fail
that that kind of would make sense but
it was that they didn't want to be seen
as uncool
um so what were your professional
thoughts after because you know i i'd
imagine there's some pressure obviously
to
um make some money on the way out yeah
so yeah if
i wanted i would have liked to have had
a podcast that made enough to pay rent
at that time but i didn't
sure
i would have wanted to be able to do
that
purely by writing but but i didn't so
i
ended up
being a working at the manhattan
institute the think tank for
probably a year starting the end of my
senior year what kind of work do you do
there i wrote for a city journal
i did their
you know did a
hosted a bunch of events zoom events at
this point because i graduated
in 2020
so covet hit two months before i
graduated so i did a bunch of zoom
events for them
um hosted some of their podcasts and
wrote for city journal
and manhattan institute gave me an award
in 2000
maybe 15 or so
they had an event for me at their center
uh it was for starting venture for
america
wow uh cool and then i i said um well i
think my opening remarks at the speech
were when i first heard about this award
uh my first question was is there money
involved
and then when i heard the answer was yes
my second question was how much
[Laughter]
money went to my organization it wasn't
like it was like i won a prize and then
they
they gave uh venture for america 25 000
which i was grateful for that's awesome
so yeah basically i worked for them
[Music]
until
i mean the plan was always
for me to be independent that was always
my plan
so i worked for them until my podcast
was big enough
that i didn't need to be aligned with
any institution i could be my own boss
which was always my goal
and so then i i amicably left
am i and
uh
my podcast grew a lot during the
pandemic it was one of those weird
things where everyone so many people are
suffering but
i'm in i'm in the exact right
industry to benefit from the fact that
everyone's stuck at home
trying to make sense of uh you know a
world that is falling apart at the seams
politically and in 2020 being ripped
apart
and they have time extra time to listen
to podcasts
so
it grew a lot to the point where i could
be independent and so i did
uh well congratulations on that so
uh tell us about
the conversations you have that you
think that people are seeking i mean i
think there is an appetite for
uh reason and rationality
uh for
even temperedness uh modern-day
um
philosophy if you will i can't like i'm
thinking about the philosophers i know
uh in
2022 and you know you could count them
uh in my mind on one hand and you're one
of them
[Laughter]
so what do you think
uh
what are the big themes that that you
explore
um that are
appealing to people
yeah so i think the
the the basic theme i explored that was
the source of
me getting a following on quillette the
my podcast ballooning
in success during 2020
was that i really think your race and
your skin color should not matter
in 99 of cases i think it doesn't matter
it's it's superficial
and what matters is
our common humanity so
the response to for a lot of people i
think which you've probably heard a
million times
is well i certainly would want it to be
that way uh but is it that way question
mark and then people would be like no so
we have to do x y right
so that that's an illogical argument
it's um
if your reply to race doesn't matter is
while the racists disagree
you're kind of proving my point
which is
the people who make race matter the
people to whom race is important are
wrong
so we shouldn't fight them by agreeing
with their basic premise we should fight
them by rejecting their premise
and
too many people have decided the right
way to fight racism
is
essentially to
agree about the underlying racist racial
essentialism blackness and whiteness are
really real things they're really very
important they're core parts of my
identity you can't really understand me
unless you understand my
how the color of my skin is an intrinsic
feature of who i am a deep feature of
who i am that separates and divides us
such that you can't really
there's some incommunicable barrier
between us
and we should organize our politics
around these
variables
people have decided that that's
the only way or the best way to respond
to
white supremacy and and racism and the
alt-right and so forth
and i i reject that i reject that
approach i
believe that
you know what is
i guess what used to be
called color blindness
is really the the only philosophically
sound
approach to have towards race and i and
i don't mean pretending not to see race
right i'm clearly asian yes i'm clearly
asian i'm clearly not
is it the comedian dove davidoff has
this joke
where he's like uh i met this woman the
other day
who said she doesn't see race
and i thought good luck describing your
attacker
it's like
just tell tell the police to look for a
man with a frown
it was like the point is obviously
everyone sees race right so that pat
phrase i don't see race
is false and misleading
but what people
the the charitable interpretation of
that is
i strive to be a person
that does not let race influence my
considered decisions
and that's the world that i want to
create i want to create a world where
people think about race
less and less and less
and and the people who do obsess about
race are more and more ostracized from
the mainstream corridors of power well
this is a very
uh
interesting counter to racism
the tagline for my presidential campaign
was humanity first so you can imagine uh
you know like this is the world that i
want
the world where
where folks
uh
don't use race as a
uh
like a factor in you know the way they
treat people the way they respond to
um
to situations
so you've heard all of the counter
arguments i'm sure and like i don't want
to be the person who like you know
belabors them since yeah i mean i'm
currently writing a book where i examine
every counter argument
that's that's out there
it's uh so
my perspective on this is
a
a little different than yours though
again i think we're aligned so i grew up
in uh majority white suburb um
in upstate new york
uh probably not as diverse as montclair
it's one of the only asian kids
uh and so
like i got picked on for being different
pretty much anyone who wasn't a white
kid got picked on for for being
different
and
i think that the culture has shifted in
ways where i like look at my boys i'm a
dad now i've got two little asian boys
nine nine and six
and i look at them i'm like huh like are
they going to experience the same sort
of thing
um and right now it doesn't seem like it
you know at least maybe not in the same
way certainly that my brother and i did
um
and so
my feeling on this is that like
that tribalism exists sort of baked into
human nature yeah um and our goal should
be to your point one
except that a certain level of tribalism
exists don't pretend that you know you
look at someone and be like oh like you
know i don't see that you're like a
different race
um and then you try and counter the
corrosive uh evil effects
of that tribalism in different ways and
i agree with you that the appeal to
universalism is
a better
working appeal than you know reinforcing
tribalism in different respects um so i
think everything i said like doesn't
disagree with you
[Laughter]
yeah i mean no some level of tribalism
is
inevitable and
not only that there are
i would even concede that there are
certain times where tribalism
is a a good thing or it's it's the
really the only way to get people to go
so far above and beyond to help their
fellow man
so like realistically
there there have been times where
you know
jews were fleeing
persecution in
one part of the world and they could
find refuge with jews that were total
strangers to them in a different part of
the world that would take them into
their homes
right and
that's a kind of altruism that is tough
to get people to do
absent tribalism actually it's like
they they accepted jews from a totally
different part of the world just because
they were part of the tribe
and that so so
i would even carve out some uni some
unique instances where
tribalism is the only plausible way of
getting people to just be super
altruistic
to
people whom would other who would
otherwise be total strangers
but in most cases
tribalism divides far more than it
brings people together and it creates
all of these inevitable resentments
when you put race into policy right like
when when biden puts
into his
restaurant relief covid policy that
he's going to put to the front of the
line people restaurants that are owned
by people of color
regardless of the need the individual
needs of of sort of the struggling
restaurants
that creates an understandable
resentment
in a white restaurant owner who's
struggling who knows all the specifics
of situation how hard he or she is
working
may even employ mostly people of color
you know like i know examples like this
and it's like
i'm being put at the back of this line
on something that is really
it's well-meaning but it's it's harming
me for some for a reason that i can't
control
at the end of the day i don't think you
can ever ask people
to
to pay for arbitrary characteristics
that they were born into it will always
create resentment no matter how you
justify it so we have to get to some
equilibrium where we can seriously focus
on
you know intergenerational poverty
neighborhoods that are stuck in
intergenerational poverty with high
crime rates
and invest heavily
in that as an independent problem
but
really create and foster a
a colorblind general
legal and political
foundation
so
uh
when i think about racism i think about
the fact that
uh
economic opportunity and educational
opportunity are vastly uneven i think um
uh the average black house household has
something like 10 percent the net worth
of the average white household and and
so i i think of it more in terms of
uh
the economic disparities and the
realities then i do
like the like the way individuals treat
each other
and i was with a black person
uh when i was running for president and
that person was like look i don't care
if like everyone loves me i just want my
schools to be better or whatever it is
right i mean that was that was really
the attitude of i mean the attitude of
all the great civil rights leaders we
look back on and admire like dr king and
byrd rustin and
they all
i mean
as compelling as as as martin luther
king was in terms of actually getting
white americans that were on the fence
to support the civil rights movement and
to
want to bring black people into the
into the fully into the american fold
they were not at the end of the day
focused on getting all white people to
like like them right like they they
understood
they had a very hard-headed approach
that you don't have to like me
but you do have to do my [ __ ] yeah you
do have to let me
be free right you have to let me
participate i want you to change this
and change that and like you know how
you feel about me right afterwards right
is less relevant yes
so i mean the truth is there's always
going to be bigots in the world
always
and there's and
you know over time i think the amount of
bigots has actually reduced somewhat as
ideas have changed as people have
met as people from different races and
ethnic groups meet each other and mingle
and
but it's never going to go away ever
it's like and and people have a totally
implicitly they have an unrealistic
attitude to this which is like for
instance no one expects the murder rate
to ever be zero even in like these
western european countries that we look
to that have far less violence than we
do and are more homogeneous than they
are yeah and are more homogeneous than
we are have very different circumstances
but
even there
no one expects to have a murder rate of
literal zero right like there's always
going to be
a guy that
finds out his wife has been cheating and
like murders the other guy and you can't
fully prevent it nor do we have that
benchmark
like a literal zero benchmark for
success and bigotry is the same way you
can never you can't fully purify
human
the human mind right
[Music]
[Music]
uh so i spoke to a
couple of people i'm going to call on
juan barbara walter wrote a book how
civil war start
and she is concerned about american
political integrity
uh and she has studied
dozens hundreds of societies around the
world in terms of
like why civil wars got going
and she found
that uh
the one of the single biggest factors is
uh what's called a super faction
um and super factions combine
race
uh with either geography or religion
into a faction that just does not shift
and uh is more likely to instigate
conflict when it feels that status is
threatened
so she compares donald trump to an
ethnic entrepreneur like uh milosevic um
in yugoslavia type figure right and that
the potential is that the republican
party slash
uh
um
you know certain uh category of of
american ends up becoming the super
faction um and leads to conflict um so
one of the things i hear you saying is
like look um there there and this is
i'll i just i won't put words in your
mouth i'll share my own perspective so
um so i i think that she's generally
correct i mean you can't dispute her you
know political science findings and
she's gone around the world and said
like hey here are things um uh and uh
there there's like this
feeling uh of agreement among uh some
americans that they're they're losing uh
their place um i've traveled the midwest
and the south have you been around the
country that way
not nearly as much as you have but well
not most yeah i don't know i've been to
spend some time in florida
some time in the carolinas
um but not nearly as much as you have
for sure oh so so the the thing that i'm
you know like i've seen
um is that that there there is a lot of
uh dislocation and suffering going on in
different parts of the country
and i think one of the
problems we face is that if you're like
a rural farmer in iowa or whatnot
right now
uh
your
concerns
um are kind of getting blended into this
uh
this racialized discussion where it's
like oh you're like uh
you know
like
you're still in the privilege class
because you're
you know like a white dude right um
hanging out in in in the sticks and and
so then there's a little bit of like
well you know like things aren't going
so well
i mean that there are there are
areas in the country where things are
really not going very well yeah um uh
and i i saw trump as kind of uh either
like a combination of like a like scream
of anger and cry for help
um
and
i think one of the things i hear you
saying is like look like that there are
ways that we can try and address
problems that affect everyone um and
that we don't necessarily that if we
kind of separate into tribes then it's
going to lead to
worse things not better things yeah
yes i mean totally i think
so that makes me think of a few things
one is
there is
you're totally right to point out the
huge economic gap between white people
and black people in terms of wealth like
that's a
that's a that's a real
power difference on the economic front
but there also is such a thing as
cultural power
right and
the cultural power of lots of
institutions and the democratic party is
disproportionately wielded i would argue
by people of color and you can
so so there's
one of the things ezra klein has said
that i really agree with is that
everyone has reason to feel like a
victim in certain domains which is
black people can point to
we have one-tenth the wealth of white
people which means
less of an ability to sort of throw
throw our weight around and lobby and
all of the
byproducts of wealth
i mean white people can point to
you know
having less cultural power
which obviously some people would
disagree with but
i would really make the case is true i'm
just going to interject something yeah
um you could throw asians
so like asian americans and i'm one um
like the conversations uh are like hey
uh you know we have a degree of like
educational economic attainment but like
culturally we're absent so right i just
want to that you could use that as like
a clear one right um in a way that you
know whites and i'd probably be tough
tougher to argue in my view but
yeah no no totally i mean and and
there's
um
[Music]
i think
white people are detecting
especially white republicans
are detecting a clear signal of contempt
from the cultural left
and unfortunately from parts of the
democratic party as well so for instance
um governor kathy hokel
around new year's when the covent
antivirals were coming out they the new
york department of health released a
document
advising
uh
doctors how to prescribe the new limited
covenant antivirals that were in scarce
supply and high demand
and the the racial aspect of that
guideline was
essentially that you you so you give it
to anyone with a comorbidity first only
people with comorbidities reasonable had
priorities but one of the comorbidities
listed as a
comorbidity was to be anything other
than white
right to be black
asian native american hispanic right
so
if it were if it were just that for
instance black people historically
oppressed and marginalized group were
prioritized
then the signal signal you might be
getting is okay democrats have a special
concern for black americans
based on history we can argue about that
but
that wasn't what it was like the signal
you're getting is
the signal you're getting is [ __ ] white
people
right like they're putting asians before
you they're putting
which aren't you know so so this is
that's the thing that aggravates the
thing you're hearing this is the thing
that aggravates me is that like if you
were so that this goes back to like a
you know an argument it's like look
things cornell west who said you know
we've tried putting black faces in high
places and like things don't change it's
like you talk about like democratic
party you know being like oh we have a
special concern for black people it's
like well then
why are the situations not improving in
the way that that you'd hope um you know
like i i so i agree with you that there
are certain messaging coming out that
like certain
uh white americans look at and be like
you know what's up with that um and and
then there's like a whole layer of white
americans who just kind of like
you know
i guess resign themselves to it and
aren't like up in arms but then but then
i think some of them will
quietly end up voting in particular ways
um i think you you saw this with um
some of the issues around schools uh you
know it's like that that there there
were certain messaging that came out and
then like parents
weren't uh weren't very excited about
some of the things that were happening
you're not a parent yet yeah but
you'll really get to this point
yeah yeah i will be one day um i'm sure
you will um so so you made a case around
um
around trying to transcend race would
that be a fair way to describe it
yeah
yeah and so there are people that have
been very attracted to your
um your thinking uh you know and and
um and then you recently came out with
like freaking music videos which is like
you're coming back to some of your
original
passions
how the heck did that come about i have
to say and if you haven't seen it we'll
probably put a link in but uh
i think uh you know like videos are very
very well done like i was
you know not not to say i mean i would
like you know you're surprised
and it wasn't
everyone thought it was going to be
yeah so continue everyone's like oh he's
a writer he wants to rap blah blah blah
it's probably going to be cringy there's
some danger signs in there i confess
yeah i mean all the signs would have
pointed to that except for the fact that
i'm a really good rapper and producer
and i've made really good videos
so
well i mean so
i mean
like that that is true yes check it out
guys are very very good so the first one
is called blasphemy came out in january
the second one's called straight a's and
came out uh february or march
and um
yeah i guess blasphemy i
made that song like a year and a half
ago
and the background to all this was when
i was like 17 i started really getting
into hip-hop i had been into hip-hop as
a kid but being into jazz kind of took
all of my focus as as a teenager
but by the time i got really got into
hip-hop
17 18 and started rapping i had all of
those skills i could play piano i could
play drums i could produce
very well so i make all my own beats i
mix all my own music
and so i started doing that
and
kind of took a break from it when i
started writing and podcasting
but came back to it and wanted to find a
way like how do i integrate this people
now know me as this guy that talks about
serious stuff and has a philosophy
podcast and talks about
blah blah blah
how can i just like break back into my
rap persona
which i i used to do rap shows all over
the city around i was like cold man cold
man you brought back cold man yeah
so
yeah i i wrote this song blasphemy and
it dealt with a lot of themes that i've
written about and and and spoken about
which is
um like can we have honest conversations
without
good faith conversations without fear of
cancellation
essentially
people are terrified to talk in a lot of
contexts and
it doesn't take that many cancellations
in order to create a culture of fear
so
that was kind of the driving impetus
beside but behind the song
and
um
i got together with this guy ian ponce
jewell who had
done a video for vince staples and had
actually done a video for kanye
which which unfortunately never got
released
but
we we got together and we made the video
we filmed it out in ukraine in kiev
actually wow
about a year ago
which we had no reason to believe was
was like unsafe then and was not unsafe
then
uh
and yeah and we filmed this video like a
hundred extras and
people have received it really well so
that sounds expensive
[Laughter]
it would have been if uh
if ian weren't the
if ian didn't have as many favors to
call upon
as as he did
um well uh you're a very impressive
musician thank you uh it's uh you know
like i i was
deeply impressed
um
i'm not as multi-talented as you uh and
[Laughter]
how much do you sell your business for
before you ran for president oh you know
i'm sure that number is buried in a
public finance center
um so
so you're you're such like a
an uncommon figure um you know a bit of
a polymath you can write rap
so
you have a book coming out like what are
the projects that you're most excited
about
yeah i'm
finishing my book this year hopefully
which deals with all the subjects we've
been talking about
here and that will come out
probably next year probably uh what is
it now 2022 yeah yeah so it'll come out
2023
and
i have my podcast conversations with
coleman i release every week
and um
and then i got my music i'm hopefully
i'm going to release an album this year
wow a full album and then would there be
a tour
quite possibly yeah we're trying to
figure that out now
uh
well sky's the limit for you i mean
it's incredible that you made a name for
yourself at such an early point and you
have a point of view that i think
a lot of americans
would be interested in
[Music]
so it seems like you traffic
largely in
the way ideas are uh communicated are
there policies that you
uh advocate that you think would help
everyone and like what i'm reminded of
was like i had a conversation with john
mcward you know john yeah yeah so i i
would dare say that you and john uh you
know sees certain things totally yeah
he's like my uh i think he's called me
his intellectual son before which i i
was like a high compliment
brilliant man which i love yeah so john
makes the argument he's like look you
know we want to help black people here
are some things you could do like and
the war on drugs like you know like a
few things he's like that that
would would be helpful for black people
and not what he sees as kind of like the
um the focus on
um like
signaling and yeah manners and the rest
of it are there things where you're like
look you want to help black people
here's what you would do
yeah so i mean i agree with all of his
prescriptions um so ending the war on
drugs was
one
there was one which
as a linguist he he suggested a certain
way of teaching reading that is
empirically much more effective
which is the phonics method of learning
reading which he thinks would would
boost basically you know early black
literacy
and
um i can't remember his his third
suggestion but i mean some of the other
things that i think
so i have some ideas about
what would be effective ways to
combat
racism right
which i
which i think are rarely
talked about so
i mean for instance i know chicago has
done this but having
uh you know traffic
uh
having uh you know tickets
automated tickets with traffic cameras
just reduce cop interactions reduce cop
interactions
cops can focus on doing more important
stuff
if you get a ticket you know it wasn't
racial profiling because cameras don't
care what you look like
i mean this it seems like a pretty clear
win-win in most cases although it's
gotten some pushback
um
i mean that that's one example of a
policy i think
would make sense to
widely implement in cities
and i'm
kind of surprised that there
was very little discussion of it when we
were all talking about police brutality
and so forth i'm gonna put you on the
spot you know but you know
uh did you have a feeling about
universal basic income when i was
campaigning on it because that that was
my that's my way of uh you know to me
uh
it would help
those uh
with the lease the most yeah
so
i mean i i kind of had mixed feelings
about it
um
it was ironically it was like the one
policy recommendation of yours that i
had mixed feelings you struggled with
yeah
it was your main one but like everything
else i was
on
really on board with um
there's just been too many times in my
life where
i
thought an economic policy was a really
good idea and then a smart economist
gave me a reason why it wasn't that my
my general confidence in
in
economic
specific economic policies has gone down
like my general confidence in my beliefs
about what is good for the economy
is low so it's it's not actually a ubi
specific criticism it's a general
skepticism that i have in my ability to
correctly discern to diagnose and
prescribe this yeah the second and third
and fourth and fifth order consequences
of any economic policy yeah i i i hear
that sounds good
to my ear you know it's
i mean one of the things that scares me
man is like i i can see the way things
are trending uh
uh where
and you know i was running for president
on this like things are getting
more and more dystopian and when i did
speak to black groups
uh you know i talked to
bishop t d jakes i talked to a national
action number i talked a lot of black
groups over the last number of years and
i would say to them it's like look
there's an economic hurricane coming
and
you know who gets hurt worse than a
hurricane
poor people
and people of color because they don't
have shelter they can't get to higher
ground right so this buzz saw that's
coming it's gonna like there's a study i
saw
that said that
uh black net worth in america will be
negative uh by you know like
i think it was like 20 40 or something
like that
um so so there there's this is my
frustration it's like there's this
notion it's like oh things are getting
better like you know black people are
coming up like and then
then you know white people you know like
there's an argument and there's some
truth to this too like white people are
coming down because you can see
things like life expectancy going down
like you know deaths and spare going up
and so then and then this goes back to
barbara walters thing it's like you know
white people feeling like they're going
down
um and uh they're going to uh respond
like extraordinarily negatively maybe
maybe even violently
um
and the cultural power you talk about is
always like oh you know like people of
color and uh and uh our marginalized
groups are like coming up and then i'm
like wait a minute like there's this
freaking ai buzz saw that's going to
come and like you know like black net
worth isn't going to be getting down not
up like like white now where it's going
to diverge sharply depending upon where
you live
in certain places it's just you know
there's going to be disintegration and
deterioration in other pockets it's
gonna
uh it's going to head up um so anyway
that that this is one of the things that
i've been struggling with a bit is that
even when i was on you know bill maher
the other day or week
um where it's like like so by virtue of
the fact i ran for president by virtue
of the fact you you know are a
philosopher and uh musician and
everything else like we're cultural
figures and so we end up arguing in
cultural parlance you know what i mean
it's like and
and
uh and so there's a sense that there's
this black cultural power which
certainly from certain perspectives
you're like and and you know when i talk
to like my asian friends
they would totally agree with this like
my cultural power is like
up here right um and then i had this
notion when i was running it's like look
there's like this underlying reality you
know there are people who are of
communities who have like certain
um prominence or visibility or the rest
of it but like the the reality is
uh is that
like there is an economic hurricane
coming it's you know like it's gonna
affect everyone um and so my argument
for ubi was like we have to try and find
different ways for people to have a path
forward
or else it's just going to end up
in like turning us against each other
deteriorating in different ways i really
agreed with your diagnosis of
the problem like the problem of
de-industrialization of sending all our
factories overseas
you know that that's been described as
sort of hitting
white america very hard but it also hit
black america there were a lot of
freaking black manufacturing workers in
detroit and like all these other places
and all these places all of these
uh you know black
cities sort of formerly great baltimore
places that hollowed out yeah um
you know that that had a huge effect on
on on black america new jersey yeah
totally so i mean that that the deaths
of despair
the stagnant wages
that whole you know the
the
returns to the top one percent just you
know going up and up climbing like crazy
and even during covid like how much
the the top 10 like wealthiest people
profited during kovit as as so many
people suffered
um
and you know in a weird way the the
biden bucks almost seemed like a mini
trial of of your idea
although it was in a time of crisis but
so like i i have no
uh
it we clearly need something like we
need we need something that
levels the playing field a little bit
and provides uh
a wider safety net to
to people in general
um as
as the economy moves forward you know i
i don't know exactly to what extent the
the ai apocalypse is coming i know
in some ways it's already calm a little
bit to certain sectors
i know that any job that requires narrow
intelligence
like
you know like chess engine type narrow
intelligence we're going to be destroyed
by ai if we haven't already
but i'm not i'm not totally convinced by
the ai apocalypse that we're going to
get general intelligence
where it's going to be cheaper to build
a robot that does like a wide array of
like sort of common sensical tasks it's
going to be cheaper to have a robot do
that than a human well one of the tough
things that's happening too now man and
you and i feel that when we're in new
york is that i don't think office
culture is coming back no way yeah that
it was it's interesting because
it's one of those things where
people just didn't realize they could do
certain things from home until they were
forced to and now a lot of people prefer
it
a lot i mean i've seen some polling and
some numbers you know the
vast majority of people
want to work from home
but the the tough part too is i think
that people who are
served the worst by this are young
people
because when you're a young person you
come in and you can build trust and
organization you kind of like absorb an
office culture and the rest of it not
people like you i mean you're going to
be a solo creative and end up
you know
like a rap star philosopher it's kind of
awesome but
but um but in like for the the average
worker trying to um build those chops
maybe become a manager and leader
themselves
i think it's much much harder virtually
um whereas if you're a little further
along in your career like me and you
have a family then you're like you know
yeah sure beam me in
um so i think it's young people that get
served the worst by the shift you know
the other people that get served the
worst the people that
uh
used to have jobs based upon folks
showing up to the office um so that's
security cleaning street vendors retail
uh you know restaurants and bars like
you name it yeah so
that there are these things like that
that are happening now that
uh you know you don't think of that as
like part of the ai apocalypse but it
kind of is because
you know it's like i also wonder if it's
part of the
if it may have bad mental health
ramifications because
i mean as annoying as it can be to come
into work every day
dude it like keeps you on the
straightening keeps you on the straight
and narrow absolutely yeah
i do think there is um
[Music]
like people need structure yeah
i think that people totally need
structure and
often they even need it when they need
it like they need to take their medicine
and eat their broccoli like
and when it
when you get when when it gets taken
away
sometimes you don't realize how
important a purpose it was serving
for you
right even though it's annoying and it's
like you got to wake up early and
all that stuff
gives you structure in a way that's
really healthy
totally yeah i mean you asked my kids
like hey do you want to go to school
don't be like no i don't know and every
time there's just here's the thing the
paradox about it is every time there's a
snow day it's like the happiest day
right and it
if you're not from a place where with
snow days
you know whatever like if you're missing
out
it was like we would as a kid we would
superstitiously flush our toilets at 8
p.m the night before snow we had all
these traditions to try to bring the
snow day like a rain like a rain dance
or something you know
and it's like the happiest day so you
extrapolate you think well if i had no
every time i i get a break from
structure
i'm incredibly happy all day so if i
just got rid of the structure i'd be
incredibly happy all the time it's like
no that's not how it works it's only fun
because you have the structure
every day right a vacation means nothing
if it's like
if your whole life is
kind of like a vacation
um not which is not to say that's what
working from home is like
but it is to say actually
having to get up and physically go to a
place
is a very different psychological
dynamic than having some zoom calls
uh i used to be an office culture guy
you know some people judge me on that
[Laughter]
when i say that i mean so a couple
experiences one i worked from home in my
mid-20s trying to start a company
i hated it company never got off the
ground i was like i can't do that again
and then i was running companies because
i was like you know the ceo
and i believe i was like you know a
fairly benign
leader and manager i wasn't like a you
know jackass um but i i thought that
having people together enabled us to
just collaborate and communicate build
relationships in a different way and
like establish what i i hoped was like a
positive team culture yeah um and so
you know like like that that was my jam
at the time like we built like
and these organizations too i was
younger then so it was like a bunch of
young people together in an office being
like yeah we're gonna do it it's gonna
be great like you know and
or organizations did um
we achieved like unlikely things now was
the office part of it like i thought it
was
um
[Laughter]
yeah i mean this is so like for instance
when covet hit and we were all
quarantining
stand-up comics
tried to do zoom comedy
and it sucked
it's like you had the best some of the
best comics in the world
trying to make people laugh i've noticed
you interview a lot of comics do you
have like uh
i had jeffrey maurer but yeah do you
have like uh an affinity for comedians i
do have an infinity affinity for
comedians i i hang out a lot at the
comedy cellar
and i become friends with some of the
comics there
um have you gone on stage done a tight
five minutes
i've done like uh three or four open
mics
done like five minutes at open mics but
not in
maybe like a year ago i was doing that
so that's not going to become part of no
cold man no i'm not passionate enough
about it to work hard at it
you know like to get good at that you
got to put in your malcolm gladwell
hours you know your 10 000
and to do that you have to intrinsically
hunger to do it like
and i don't have that hunger for it
um otherwise i would because i love
comedy
um
but yeah like you know they try to do
that stuff on zoom and it's like it
turns out it doesn't really matter how
funny you are
it's hard to be funny over zoom like
it's not the same you know i uh saw dave
chappelle during um kovid and he had the
opposite take of the zoom thing which
was like i'm going to get together
people in real life in a cornfield in
ohio and we're going to do this thing
yeah we're going to separate the mass
test everyone yeah and they did it yeah
and then and they they did it that was
such an oasis um it's hard to believe
that were you at that yeah oh that's
awesome yeah because chappelle supported
your campaign he did his shows to
support you right yeah yeah yeah and so
then i went out to ohio during
um during those shows i actually make a
tiny tiny cameo in his
uh documentary about those shows um
proof
i was there i've got like a you know
chappelle
camp chappelle t-shirt to prove it too
um
[Laughter]
so but he took the other way he was like
you know no way anyone's gonna do this
stuff yeah remotely like right you get
people together right
yeah i've seen chappelle twice in the
past
three months i've seen i saw him do a
show at the cellar in a show at the
stand
it was great that's fun uh did you meet
him does he know you yeah i said hi to
him like hi i'm coleman but no not other
than that
uh well i think you'd enjoy aspects of
uh
your
you know music you might you know i mean
i i mean maybe yeah i mean i mean seen i
mean he's a bit though you know i think
he's got a different and a different
take on some issues than you do
which i mean it's true of every two of
us all
[Music]
it's it's interesting man i like as as i
was sitting with you so there there's
like uh
i want let's see i'm gonna try and
that's something that that that's been
weighing on me
um
so i think i can see why some people
take issue with your approach which as
you can tell i'm generally aligned with
so here's how i'm aligned with it and
here's how i probably differ from it
so i'm aligned in the senses like look
we all see race there is a certain
amount of tribalism trying to go around
saying like we're going to like stamp
out all elements of racism in everyone's
minds and hearts and souls is like well
that's not a realistic approach to me a
realistic approach is to try and
alleviate some of the
you know more evil corrosive elements of
racism that you can see around us like
to me like intergenerational poverty
seems unnecessary like maybe we can
attack that like you know you know
certain things though my preferred way
of attacking things are by saying like
look let's alleviate poverty and then
not focus on particular um you know like
divisions because turns out poverty
affects just about everyone of every
group
um so
you know so there are things that
um like i'm pushing for that i think
will help everyone will help people who
have uh the least the most which does
overlap with certain groups and like
certain groups of color
um and then there's like a positive
version of identity politics that i
think in some ways like dave might
embody which is like dave's like very
very
no he doesn't i mean he wouldn't use the
word term identity politics like he's
not for that but
[Laughter]
but it's like like that there's like a
positive version
um like you know it's like some of my
friends who are very avowedly um black
as an example but like they're but
they're kind of they're very elevating
um they're they're not adversarial they
don't go in like you know uh like
um
uh in an accusatory or a negative way to
other people and be like you know
like they're just elevating um and then
there's like this negative version
um where it is much more like uh
adversarial and contentious and in my
view like not as productive because like
if you're you know putting someone in a
corner and they'll
like they tend to come come back
um at you
so uh you know like i i feel like
there's like an
elevating approach that certain leaders
take that like i i'm cool with
like i i have a bigger issue with some
like the you know the like the negative
approaches that some people
take um and it seems like you're in a
slightly different place where you're
like look like uh
um
that uh
that there aren't really
as positive uh approaches that like even
us accepting the essentialism is kind of
um you know
like already conceding too much is that
a fair characterization i think that's
directionally true i mean like i said
earlier there are certain
things i would acknowledge where
tribalism leads people to
do good things that they it's hard to
do
absent tribalism
but i you know i see
i mean for every one of those i feel
like i see a hundred or a thousand
examples of
people
invoking race or identity in ways that
harm the conversation
um
i mean like even
to take dave as
as an example and i i know he's your
friend
i love him i think he's the greatest of
all time but
the way he invoked race in his latest
special where he was talking about trans
issues right he was talking about trans
and
the whole thing essentially became a
competition between
how much bigotry trans people have
experienced and how much bigotry black
people have experienced
and it became this oppression olympics
thing where
dave would essentially say
well why aren't black people getting
attention how come trans people are
getting so much attention for their
bigotry you like we're the real victims
and that short-circuited the
conversation then it just becomes
my identity versus yours
and i thought that that he was sort of
falling back on this
well i'm i can't be a bigot
against trans because i'm black
which logically is not necessarily true
and like i i don't think
he is a bigot necessarily towards trans
people but
the way that the race card was played in
that conversation
felt like to me a coarsening of the
conversation it felt like the
conversation was worse precisely because
he invoked
him his his being black
as a
trump card or as
some kind of
card to play in the conversation about
trans and you know that
felt to me a
it's like it's it's such a tempting
thing to do like when you have a card to
play to play it especially when you're
being accused
and
you know piled upon as dave constantly
is for
for being one of the few people you know
brave enough to joke about a sacred cow
like like trans
issues right now but
it's just it almost always
is a way of not having the most
honest and
common ground finding
conversation
um
have you
uh
have you know i was fighting by
something was that you're like your
first public uh opining on
maybe on that special i'm not special i
was just wondering whether you'd maybe
you'd give it anything no i haven't said
that exact thing before
ever i was just curious
um yeah i saw dave dave thereafter and
you know like dave is very very
like he's got the height of a rhinoceros
so yeah things like
you know things that would affect other
people i'm happy to say you know like
kind of come and go where he's concerned
um just some something i'd admire about
him um there's a lot on my i agree with
you he's the best of all time
um and don't just say that because i
know i was a huge fan of his beforehand
so yeah i mean he was the first comedian
i loved really yeah so the fact that
when i first met him and then he started
he started supporting the presidential i
was like well yeah oh my god he must
have been over the moon that's
incredible yeah i mean the presidential
man it was such like a freaking
i look you know it's funny like someone
said it to me the other day it was like
it's like type 2 enjoyment which is like
at the time was i enjoying myself i mean
it was like hard work i was like
grinding all the time type 2 enjoyment
yeah so type 2 enjoyment was like uh you
know like you look back at it after the
fact you'd be like oh that was yeah yeah
it's like at the time was i like
enjoying myself day to day i mean i was
like away from my family for weeks at a
time exhausted
exhausted smiling muscles got tired yeah
i mean i was in iowa so much and i'll
describe this like you know system like
this is what comes to my mind
um so i was a spread out state there's
no way to travel it that's not by car
when you really upgraded at a certain
point you had a bus so that was like the
greatest greatest thing of all time but
that was not for months
so the the punctuation mark when i was
campaigning was rest stops
was that um
that that uh it would be like between
events we would stop at a gas station
and those would be my moments of joy
we would stop at a rest stop and i'd be
like i think i'll take type 1 enjoyment
thanks
did not sound that good so i'd be like
yay and then i'd go into the rest stop
and then i would buy something that i
would like
um and
it was tough because
i you know you just wanted to buy
comfort food because you're like you
know like so but i didn't want to you
know type two enjoyment leads to type 2
diabetes
so
[Laughter]
so i would try and split the difference
so i would get a lot of nuts or popcorn
where i would say like this is not
you know
uh potato chips so like i'm in the clear
it's like snacky um so those those would
be like my
um my joyous interludes is like we
stopped at the rest stop i had two
minutes to go in and buy
like uh you know like a green tea and
pistachios or whatever so i was saying
to zach before you got here um before we
were recording that following you
run for president and reading your book
about it
is is like um
maybe the only but
certainly one of the only times that you
feel like you are witnessing a normal
person
run for president
and you were in this
golden zone where
if you had succeeded if and actually
become president
i think the version of the story
we we would have heard wouldn't have
really been
what it is it wouldn't have felt that
way because
you reach this untouchable zone where
it's like
image management now becomes a matter of
like national security and it's more
difficult to give a really raw honest
take until maybe 20 years after it's
whatever
but if you have no chance to begin with
then it's not interesting then you're
just a normal guy like
with pipe dreams but you were in this
golden zone where you really had a a
real chance
oh thank you
but you were also able to tell the story
in a way that's like
this actually looks like what it would
be for like a normal person to run for
president and and you never get to
hear the story from that angle it's it
was so cool oh thank you man i i tried
to share it while it was happening
because i was trying to you know compete
and win yeah um i'm really glad i
documented in the book when i did
because
it was
relatively
fresh but i'd also blocked a lot of it
out
like i really you know my recollection
of those months is like very dim because
i was such like this
focused instrument and
uh
yeah um
but i agree with you like you know like
i was still myself and it was relevant
yeah so those two things were true and
you just you you get the sense that
career politicians and this is one
reason trump was successful
career politicians have so altered
their palette of emotions and responses
um
i mean and also this is why i show like
veep is hilarious to to watch uh which
by the way is shockingly accurate yeah
like to watch how she
um
like the person she becomes as a result
of
being on stage all the time
it's like
you almost can't have normal emotions
right it's like you
you're on stage so much of the time it's
just totally
disorienting and makes you and you
discuss this in your book
it it it really makes you
in some ways a worse person oh yeah yeah
so i think this is the problem with
with many professions like surgery for
instance
after you've done a thousand surgeries
or after you've been working in an er
room for
some length of time
well there's no way you can actually
feel
what's happening in the room the way
that i would feel it if i was on my
first day in an er right
and that's actually a requirement of the
job so you don't want that you don't
want that you want you need to acquire a
certain numbness
but on the flip side and i think people
have also experienced this in from
doctors and in hospitals
once you have that numbness it can lead
you to do
to be much more cruel and dismissive of
people's pain
right it's like
it's a double-edged sword because you
need it in order to survive the job for
any length of time to not quit out of
pure
distress and pain but then it allows you
to just be totally numb to people's pain
for and do horrible things and
politics is like that and we get that
sense from
um from career politicians
and so you know
that's one reason it was really
interesting to
watch you i i think you just summed up
the one of the greatest problems in
american life my my friend
which is that we have these dynamics of
success within marketplaces that in
order to succeed in the vast vast
majority of them you have to kind of
become an automaton
you know like i now know a ton of media
figures most of them have a lot of the
same things you're talking about as
political figures where they become kind
of
uh performers and automatons
uh you know let's say
and some of your buddies from columbia
will resemble this someday it's like
let's say you're a successful financier
you also end up becoming kind of this
like cold-blooded calculating
uh
pandemic happens
and it's not 10 seconds before you're
thinking oh which stock should i invest
in yeah it's like you don't even for one
you have no time to think about the
people that are going to die and it's
like okay in one sense it's like you're
not going to be able to help them anyway
but
is that the kind of person you want to
become
so it's like there's a war in ukraine
okay which stock am i going to invest
like we've turned up the market
incentives to such a high degree
that now and just about everyone's
subject to them um and so
in order to succeed then you kind of
remove certain aspects of humanity uh
and and and
then uh that's like the
um the progression um you know certainly
seen in politics media yes
business of course
uh you know one of the last bastions
maybe of the opposite that i see it's
like flailing around and dying
is art
you know it's like are there market
incentives attached to art like of
course you know and then you there's
certain things that you do i mean one of
the reasons why you're so interesting is
that you're such an iconoclast like you
know it's genuine you're like you know
you think you genuinely did arrive at
what you
think because you think those those
things yeah
right and it is very much against the
grain
um
but that this
this is what uh my my core challenge is
for us all right now
uh is that the market dynamics are gonna
get stronger and stronger we're gonna
lead more and more people like in
certain directions
uh and the market dynamics are also
going to end up excluding like tons and
tons of people most of whom i have been
stunned by the fact that we had this
enhanced child tax credit that helped
like get millions of kids out of poverty
and like help
millions of families tens of millions
families
um and then they discontinued in january
and then there there's been not like
some kind of like massive uh furor like
you you would think it's like tens of
millions of parents but like wait a
minute what like you know
what just happened yeah um where there's
like this mass of the voiceless
um that aren't successful within like
the market
doctrines and then like turns out we
don't pay attention to them what they
like don't have
massive followings and like our system
is less and less responsive to um to
people um and
uh
like the the coarsening you're
describing this inhumanity like i think
that's the core challenge the question
is how do we humanize um i i like the
fact that you're trying to make
universal cases um you know i think that
could be
a part of it
uh there was a point i'm older than you
are like in the 70s and 80s like there
was like this coreness to like an
american identity maybe because there
were only three tv channels which is
like we also watch the same [ __ ] right
so it's like someone asked me at that
point what being an american was like
let's see i eat hamburgers and hot dogs
and pizza and i watch
like you know the the
same programs everyone else right uh i
guess that's it you know yeah you know
as the child of immigrants um you know
like that was oh the other things what
am i talking about gotta play some
sports follow some sports
um
yeah i had i had a good deal of that
culture growing up
but definitely not to the extent
of
probably your generation
oh yeah for sure because you know you
had more channels more channels yeah
well you know my parents didn't believe
in cable so
until i was 11 years old i think i only
had
public access channels and like zero
through channel zero through pbs 13.
i had no cable um it's probably why
you're so smart my friend cable the guy
that's what my mom would have said
[Laughter]
your mom mom was an incredible person
and she'd be very very proud of you
thank you thank you um
[Music]
one thing i just thought of is like so
this we're talking about this
inauthenticity of politicians
um
this is the reason why politicians can't
apologize
it's like
politicians
we we know the apology is insincere
because we know everything is insincere
that's why politicians
get penalized when they apologize
right like normally if your friend if
your friend
[ __ ] up with you
or your boyfriend your girlfriend your
husband your wife and they give you
they give you like an apology that you
can really see that they feel it they
feel guilty for what they said or did
that does something good with you right
that your estimation of them goes up as
opposed to if they just
whatever double down yeah if paul when
politicians apologize no matter how
sincere they try to be
it never works it makes them look worse
and so they don't do it and the
politicians that never apologize like
trump are enormously successful
whereas someone like joe rogan
when he apologizes
it actually makes your opinion of him go
up as if he were your friend or someone
you knew
that's the normal dynamic of human
psychology the politician dynamic is
because we know it's all sincere on some
level
that we don't often acknowledge
the the
rules aren't the same apologies don't
work
um and that's just one way where i see
that
come to light
yeah
political culture man it's not going
well
not enough
[Laughter]
not enough humanity too much yeah uh
uh and you see information people crave
authenticity right it's like okay trump
he lied all the time we all know it
but he was authentic
in some way
like he he really said what was on the
top of his mind it was not scripted
and you knew it wasn't scripted because
it might contradict what he said 10
minutes ago
it was not focus grouped
um like he really felt authentic to
people
as opposed to someone like hillary
and uh
the measure of how much people crave
that is that they put up with a lot of
you know a lot of trump voters didn't
like everything about him you know they
didn't like that he
you know they didn't like the porn star
fiasco they didn't you know they were
they were normal people in that sense
like they were good honest people and
but they create they craved part of what
they craved was just like
a break from
the constant phoniness
of it all
and one thing i think i liked and many
people liked about your campaign
is that there was not
even a hint of sneering at the trump
voter
right
there was like obviously there was
hillary clinton her deplorables comment
was
the tip of an iceberg which is sort of a
feeling of all these people who voted
for trump
are
bigots right or or in some way i have
family members who voted for trump so
yeah i know morally defunct but that
thank you for there is not even a hint
of it with you there was not even a
suggestion
like a trump voter could listen to you
and feel like you don't hate him at all
and and maybe i should vote for him and
maybe like
you're
you know you're actually the substance
of
whatever the concerns that led me to
trump were
you know i i was
proud of the fact that 42 percent of my
supporters said they weren't sure if
they're going to support the democratic
nominee because they were independents
or in some cases republicans
um
yeah and i don't i don't judge them man
i mean you know just human beings like
doing what they thought right the right
thing to do was and i think this is this
is a big lesson of
a big lesson that people should
internalize
is that at the end of the day
people are not going to vote for you if
they feel you are looking down on them
and it's
it's
it's um
[Music]
it's not just a matter of
not making a gaffe like hillary made
with deplorables like there are many
other ways in which people feel like
you're kind of giving them the finger
like you're saying
they're not such a great person
or people like them are not such a great
person and if people feel that from you
left right center
doesn't matter they will not they don't
nothing else you say is ever going to
matter
well thanks for noting that i had a
friend who had a devoted um
trump supporting mom
who said that yang is the only
one i i'd consider the other side
because i just don't think he's judging
me at all
and i i don't judge that person uh you
know if i have judgment about anything
right now
it's the fact that
like our system has gotten so
uh demented and that people
there are still so many people that are
like accepting of certain things and
like the guys this doesn't make sense
anymore like you know we gotta
try and
um get you know change things but yeah
there's so much institutionalization
baked in and dc is very
institutionalized uh politics media i
mean these are some of and you read my
book so you have a sense of it yep um
and even more than
is even more than i thought i did learn
some things about
you know like the just like the habits
of media the ingrained habits of media
that are anti-change basically in
principle
yeah and i learned it myself man up
close and personal um and and it was the
book was my trying to process what the
heck that i'd just gone through because
like you said it's like i
you know i was like oh i thought a
fairly regular person who ran for
president
um and uh you know i'm i'm grateful for
people like you who gave me a shot and
you know gave me a look um and in some
cases supported me uh coleman you are uh
an incredible voice of the next
generation um i can't wait to see what
you do next and hopefully i'll be a part
of it in some way like i'd love to
to be helpful if i can thank you andrew
thank you
no appreciate the heck out of you coming
in
coleman hughes yeah
forward with andrew yang is produced and
edited by mark finder media find us
wherever you listen to podcasts watch us
on youtube and subscribe today if you
like the show leave us a review on
spotify or apple podcasts and let's move
the country forward
you